let's bring in a brit now who uh did two
tours of afghanistan labour mayor of
south yorkshire and mp as well for
barnsley central joining us is dan
jarvis hello to mr jarvis thanks for
joining us was it worth it
well that's the question that many of us
are asking ourselves we invested a huge
amount of sacrifice and effort in
afghanistan over 20 years and it's been
heartbreaking in recent days talking to
the families who lost loved ones 457
british soldiers lost their lives in
afghanistan thousands more sustained
injuries that changed their lives
forever so we're all asking that
question and in the end do you have to
conclude that no it wasn't worth it and
that is heartbreaking to have to admit i
think we did make progress i think all
of those who served in afghanistan can
be extremely proud of their service but
right now given the unfolding horrors
that we're seeing in afghanistan it's
impossible to conclude that that effort
that sacrifice that we committed over
such a long time was worth it because
for most people they just don't think
that it was i asked the foreign
secretary that question this morning i
asked the defense secretary that
question yesterday they both said that
it was worth it because it provided 20
years of stability for the young
population of afghanistan you disagree
i i don't in all good conscience think
that you can justify the effort and the
sacrifice that we committed to the
country giving what's happened in recent
time it certainly is the case that real
progress was made in the period of time
that we were committed to the country in
terms of the protection of women and
girls the number of girls who were able
to engage with education the number of
women who until relatively recently were
members of the afghan parliament and
serving in the judiciary
real progress was made but that is being
unraveled as we speak and as each hour
goes by i think it's really important
that we do acknowledge and continue to
be proud of the service of the very
brave men and women who stepped forward
in our armed forces and went to
afghanistan huge personal risk to
themselves we can be proud of that
commitment what i think we do now
is is redouble our efforts
diplomatically we
have been engaged in that country for a
long period of time i think we should
retain a commitment to afghanistan i
think it's in our national interest to
do so for the benefit of the afghan
population but also given the effort and
the sacrifice that we've invested i
think it would be morally reprehensible
and strategically naive to completely
abandon the country so i hope we'll see
a stepping up of statecraft if you like
and and governments uh across the world
but led by the british and american
governments
re-engaging having a pragmatic position
when it comes to the new administration
in uh afghanistan and seeing what can be
done to avert a humanitarian catastrophe
because that's what we're looking at if
we don't engage and if we don't try and
invest in that country given everything
that we put in over the previous
generation or so it's easy to give the
government a kicking and to say how
could they not have seen what was going
to happen but they rely on the top brass
and the chief of the general staff just
two weeks ago less than two weeks ago
was saying that we shouldn't give up on
the afghan security services he was very
wrong
yes he was no one person
is accountable for the strategic failure
that we've seen in afghanistan the most
catastrophic miscalculation that's taken
place in recent time about the ability
of the afghan government and the afghan
national security forces to withstand
the pressures that would inevitably come
from the taliban once the americans
departed by the way the manner of their
departure left much to be desired and
from the point at which that they left
the country in the dead of night i think
there was something of an inevitability
that the country would fall again to the
taliban
but this is happening on the
government's watch i listened to
president biden's speech with some
interest last night i don't think
history will judge kindly his handling
of the situation in recent times and
what i hope we will see
is an effort to engage regional partners
there's a hugely important role for
pakistan for iran and for others to play
in terms of seeking to mitigate the
worst of a humanitarian crisis and i
think whilst clearly we're not going to
be pulling military leavers in the very
near future to seek to affect the
situation in afghanistan there is other
influence that we can use albeit that
may be limited in terms of diplomatic
and economic leverage so i want to see a
redoubling of the international efforts
i want to see the british government
playing a leading role i want to see the
prime minister as the chair of the g7
engaging with partner nations to look at
the art of the possible what can be done
what pressure can be applied to the
taliban regime in kabul that doesn't
mean recognizing them formally but it is
in our interest to enter into dialogue
with them we're still in the process of
recovering british passport holders and
other entitled personnel to safety from
afghanistan that process will be made
much easier if we've got some sort of
diplomatic relationship so that work
needs to be happening right now how
do you feel
about um our politicians
engaging in dialogue with the taliban
who were people
that shot your friends and colleagues
well of course from a personal point of
view it is a particularly bitter pill to
have to swallow but we need to be
pragmatic about it there is a new norm
now in afghanistan and it is in our
country's national interest not to
abandon the country not to look away but
to remain engaged to look at what
diplomatic relations can be established
as i say that doesn't mean formally
recognizing the new administration
but we should be having dialogue with
them we should be looking to see
what humanitarian activities can be
taking place now and in the near future
we've got to have some sort of working
relationship we currently have a british
military operation underway to take
british personnel out of afghanistan
that will be made much easier if some
kind of agreement can be reached in the
short term to provide safe passage for
those who want to leave the country so
i'm obviously not particularly wild
about the fact that there does need to
be some contact with the taliban given
you know all of the difficulties we've
obviously experienced with them in the
past but it is in our national interest
to do so and i hope very much that
through the foreign office and through
other channels conversations are taking
place to minimize the risks to our uk
forces who are currently conducting a
difficult and dangerous operation and
we're already starting to think about
what activities can be put in place to
avert a humanitarian catastrophe because
if that doesn't happen we will see very
significant suffering and it's the
afghan people and other countries in the
region who will suffer as a consequence
okay for now thank you